we're all winners yo all winners roma
stars born the favorite I love the black
cleansing I love green book glow which
is like our favorite show right now this
year I love the Roma you know I love
spider-man it to the spider-verse
minding the gap let the Sun Shine in the
rider I mean this is a really good year
for films those are actually a really
big fan of that show my favorite star is
born' it's great bohemian rhapsody'
place was very good win an award tonight
yeah Roma it was pretty extraordinary
vice of course Adamek a star is born
that star is bought a movie that wasn't
nominated here I thought that was a main
to call searching with John Cho one of
my favorite films of the year and I hope
John Cho gets an Oscar nom I really
really love that concept and Manson pose
absolutely can you ever forgive me
because of Melissa McCarthy's portrayal
it was so real and flawed and
heartbreaking but also funny aged she
sort of like hit it on all my with a kid
recently so the answer is I've seen
almost none of these films I
contractually had to watch black
Klansmen twice so I watched it I would
love to meet Lady gaga I'm excited to
meet gaga she's pretty epic I'm excited
to see gaga again I met her but I want
to meet Lady gaga again because she's
big she's the coolest mayor I just was
within Lady Gaga's train and it felt
amazing yeah she's incredible and just a
huge role model for me
Elsie Fisher because I thought her
performance in eighth grade was just so
real and it really just like affected me
inside Bradley Cooper he is quickly also
proving a role model for me as well
Bradley Cooper cuz we're old friends and
you know fingers crossed first star is
born honestly I want to be central Oh
Sandra Oh Sandra Oh's like yeah that's
me up there for me for sure I'm really
excited to be kanjuro actually
I've been in my repairs for a long time
Sam Elliot he's right here and I'm I'm
sweating a lot that's really cool yeah I
know there's some cool people out here I
was walking behind Jamie Lee Curtis when
I first got here that's pretty cool
I'm excited to meet Jessica Chastain
come here sidenote I worked at their
interstellar I think Maha Shiva is one
of my favorite dudes at the moment of
course Amy Adams and Spike Lee I believe
I'm supposed to be seated with Janelle
Monae and Chinna Rodriguez
so I'm just trying to you know just
welcome to the table Oh
[Music]